Cómo andas o no tuve Menos intuiciones
ahora no en este restaurante de cocina
gourmet en Toscana Juan Camilo Quintero
dirige una brigada de 18 personas
este chef colombiano de 33 años es una
de las revelaciones del selecto mundo de
la alta cocina en Italia combinando
técnicas Sabores y siguiendo un objetivo
contar aquí en Italia en Europa la lo
maravilloso y lo lindo que es Colombia
su cultura sus productos Entonces
siempre vas a notar una influencia
exótica la fruta exótica como la hierbas
el cilantro y demás que te permitirá
viajar viajar con el paladar a través de
recetas como esta a base de hoja de
plátano la hoja de plátano va a sacarle
el aroma de la hoja que luego
envolviendo el producto va a
aromatizarse No desde su llegada a
Italia Hace 13 años la trayectoria de
Juan Camilo ha sido fulgurante en el
2020 su restaurante recibió una estrella
michelín la recompensa más co del mundo
gastronómico a la cual se suma una
estrella michelín verde que premia los
esfuerzos en favor de la sostenibilidad
lo ecológico y lo social gracias a
proyectos como este huerto orgánico a
pocos pasos de su restaurante en el cual
trabajan personas con discapacidad nos
da la posibilidad de tener hierbas y
vegetales frescos en primavera salen las
arvejas las habas los hinojos el
restaurante como actividad económica es
depredadora como muchas otras por la
lógica de la distribución no del comprar
volúmenes de comida producir es hora de
que los cocineros y el consumidor
también se interrogue si lo que estamos
poniendo en los platos en los menús de
los restaurantes es correcto no en su
cocina Juana boga por el mínimo
desperdicio de ingredientes cada plato
es un trabajo minucioso fruto del
esfuerzo y la dedicación de Este joven
talento decidido a seguir conquistando
los paladares más exigentes del viejo
continente